[Music]
at any orchestra performance the full
range of human emotion can be on display
but the kiev symphony orchestra is
practicing playing a different sort of
tune as it begins a european tour with a
special assignment from ukrainian
authorities
[Music]
our concerts are truly a cultural
mission
in ukraine we say there's a cultural
front
it's not escaping the wall it's another
aspect of the wall
each strum a distraction from the
reality back home and a way for
musicians to express the feelings that
can't be summed up with words
being a professional artist on the world
stage is very very important right now
because we have access to people's souls
through music and art we speak to souls
we transmit our pain and desire our
aspirations to hearts through music
he's only been with the orchestra for a
week and a half but italian conductor
luigi gagero says he's never seen
rehearsals like this before and he hopes
the tour will last until the end of the
war whenever that might be
they don't just feel nostalgia for a job
they feel nostalgia for the very reason
of their existence which is music it's
like the air they breathe and finally
they can breathe again
[Music]
back in ukraine a familiar melody is
played during dark nights below ground
and when people of kharkiv emerge to
take stock of what else they've lost
for those sheltering in metro stations
the music brings far more
[Music]
music is art it is life it is a ray of
light that helps our souls survive it
brightens our lives and keeps us away
from panicking the darkness and gloom of
this war the bitterness music art they
give us hope for the future
hope for peace in this world that life
will continue and that the light will
win over the darkness
that hope in the darkest of days
is getting these people through
andrew chappelle al jazeera